philosophy lecturer in the United States
has stirred anger after calling
Americans who live in rural areas bad
people who deserve uncomfortable lives
his tweets since been deleted
Ayana CLE embraced the bashing of rural
Americans they as a group are bad people
who have made bad life decisions some I
assume are good people but this
nostalgia for some imagined postural way
of life is stupid and we should shame
people who aren't Pro City Hey Texan
Kernan stereotyping is a weak way to
make a point the assumptions about rural
people are Ella to stand cruel
you know everything people think is
wrong with higher education but he did
not speak for professors try feeding
yourself without a farmer body okay the
person at the center of all this is
Jackson Kern Ian who graduated from
Harvard University in 2012 he then
taught at least 11 philosophy courses at
the University of California Berkeley
Kearney and later apologized for the
tone of what he wrote but not for the
ideas his Twitter accounts also now been
deleted Barkley stressed that the
university doesn't have an elitist
approach towards any social group while
Julio Rivera of reactionary times.com
says that the gap between coastal and
Heartland America is widening one of
those things where you know you don't
obstruct people's freedom of speech but
at the same time you have to be careful
who's saying what because these are
actually the the people who are in
charge of shaping the minds and they're
the elite sectors of academia and the
politics you know the so-called ruling
class these people think that there's so
much better than just regular old
Heartland Americans they think they're
heartland Americans are less intelligent
academically inferior and and just you
know negative in a lot of different ways
and I think it's really an American
there's a lot of social changes that are
you know being enacted right now in
America in the name of progressivism but
it's not really progressing the country
it's actually causing a regress
and a lot of people were having problems
you having all sorts of new mental
health diagnosis --es and you know
graduation rates are still horrible in
the inner cities you know these places
that continually elect these liberals
are actually performing the worse
you